A sand dune in Indiana has started swallowing
people walking on its face.
It's like nature is fighting back.
Hello there people of House Atreides, Trace
here reporting on a horrrrrible thing for
DNews.
Science is now exploring how and why sand
dunes will eat you.
No I'm not talking about the lighting sand
or pit of Sarlacc, Arrakis or any of that.
I'm talking about REAL SAND ON REAL DUNES
HERE ON EARTH THAT CAN SWALLOW YOU WHOLE.
The Indiana Dunes National Lakeshore is gorgeous,
I've been there a few times and it's beautiful,
but it seems, it has the potential to be deadly.
Picture this, six-year-old boy walking down
a sand dune next to a beautiful freshwater
inland sea.
Then suddenly, without warning, he disappears.
His parents run screaming toward the boy and
find nothing but sand.
A hole had appeared below this kids feet and
before he OR his nearby parents could do anything
he had disappeared beneath the sand!!
Three hours later, and eleven feet down, emergency
personnel pulled him out!
ELEVEN FEET.
Nearby, was a geologist from Indiana University
Northwest and she is now one of many studying
the dunes to find the cause of this sand swallowing.
She believes we're seeing a new geological
phenomenon forming right under our feet.
More holes have appeared and disappeared and
to find out what's going on, the National
Park Service is ON THE CASE.
They're using GPS, ground penetrating radar
and other fancy technology to explore what's
going on under the surface of this 200 foot
pile of sand.
But so far they're not sure what's happening.
Because dunes SHOULDN'T HAVE HOLES!
See, sand dunes form when the wind drops the
stuff it's carrying in the same spot for thousands
of years.
When the wind blows over a sandy region, like
the warm beaches of Lake Michigan, sand particles
are pulled along with it -- bouncing a few
inches above the surface.
If something blocks the flow of sand, like
denser air, mountains, opposing wind forces,
or even a small ridge; then WHAMMY, a dune
will form.
When conditions are perfect, giant dunes like
Mount Baldy can form.
When you build a dune like this, one particle
of sand at a time, there's not a lot of room
for air or water to get trapped inside the
sandy mountain.
Sinkholes // which are terrifying // form
when erosion removes the support structure
under a layer of earth.
Quicksand is the same, it's water erosion
of the layers UNDER the sand.
So, unlike quicksand or sinkholes there's
nothing under there making room for people
to be sucked in.
One hypothesis claims trees and structures
once on a plain around the dune have now been
swallowed by this shifting mountain and as
they rot they leave spaces for more sand to
fall in.
But that doesn't fully explain the problem.
Science is bumfuzzled!
So what's the fix?
The National Park Service isn't sure.
Like deserts and marshes, dunes are a delicate
balance of nature.
Too much plant life solidifies the ground
creating a hill, too little and the dune blows
away.
Baldy is in a sweet spot where the whole dune
can grow and shift; and it's currently moving
inland away from the lake, year after year.
Dunes in China are going the same way, threatening
villages as they move 65 feet (20M) every
year.
For the moment, the dune is close to the public
while they research what could be causing
these collapses, but this is a REAL science
mystery!
What do you think could be causing these holes?
You should tell us your own cocka-mamy theories
down in the comments, I'm sure you've got
an idea.
Subscribe for more awesome DNews videos every
day of the week and if you want to say "hi!"
come to twitter and search for me at-tracedominguez
or at-dnews!
Thanks for watching today!
We have the best viewers on this crazy-ass
website.
See you next time, and hey, watch your step.